u.s president joe biden's trip to
brussels to meet leaders of nato the g7
and european union was aimed at rallying
western allies to find ways to stop
russia's war in ukraine and send a
message to moscow that the west is
united nato has never never been more
united than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine biden
said the u.s would commit one billion
dollars in humanitarian aid to ukraine
and the western allies would impose a
raft of new sanctions on moscow we're
also announcing new sanctions
of more than 400 individuals and
entities aligned
with in alignment with the european
union
more than 300 members of the duma
oligarchs and russian defense companies
that fuel the russian war machine
earlier in the day ukraine's president
addressed nato leaders and asked the
military alliance for more help to fight
russian forces
the ukrainian army has been resisting
for a month in unequal conditions and i
have been repeating the same thing for a
month now to save people and our cities
ukraine needs military assistance
without any restrictions
nato continues to reject zelinski's
request for a no-fly zone over ukraine
over fears that it could escalate the
conflict but the alliance has agreed to
send more weapons to kiev as well as
equipment to deal with a possible
chemical or biological attack as
concerns grow that russia's invasion
could take an even more sinister turn
any use of chemical
weapons will
totally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international law
and
it will have uh wide spread consequences
and of course be extremely dangerous
biden joined eu leaders at the end of
the day for a summit focused on ways to
wean the block off its reliance on
russian energy supplies on friday the
u.s president will travel to warsaw to
show support for poland which has
welcomed the majority of ukraine's
refugees biden wants the west to keep up
sanctions pressure on the kremlin but
the question is whether it will be
enough to stop vladimir putin's war as
it enters a second month natasha butler
al jazeera brussels